though house darrenden titled themselves
storm kings they were little more than
gusts
their kingdom in the stormlands had been
doddering to its end for the past few
centuries helped along by other houses
most of all by house horror who were
nearly finished with a monstrous castle
at harrenhal
too large and too costly a seat to rule
only the riverlands
king argilac knew where the ironborn
would soon turn
you'd think a king who wanted to keep
his crown would be wary of a man with
fire breathing monsters but king argilac
darunden wasn't called the arrogant for
nothing
determined to arrest his family's
decline he sent an envoy to dragonstone
to enlist aegon targaryen and his
dragons against his enemies
in exchange agalek offered lands he
didn't have and a wife aegon didn't need
for as the valerians did aegon had wed
his elder sister visenya
then as the valerians didn't he took the
younger rhaenys as well
two sisters two wives
perhaps that's why he was so keen to get
off dragonstone
aegon countered argilac with courtesy
he sent his own envoy requesting that
princess duranden's hand be given
instead to aegon's closest friend and
rumored half-brother orris baratheon
argoluck answered with a box and a note
these are the only hands your boss shall
have of me
inside the box were the hands of aegon's
envoy
how long had aegon been waiting for such
a pretext
as his army prepared to sail ravens flew
to every great lord of the seven
kingdoms
all bore the same message from this day
forth there would be but one king in
westeros
those who bent the knee to aegon of
house targaryen would keep their lands
and titles
those who took up arms against him would
be thrown down humbled and destroyed
poor old argilac he couldn't even match
aegon in arrogance
while aegon marched on harrenhal after
his coronation
oris baratheon had taken most of his
forces and his queen rhaenys with her
dragon south to deal with the excuse for
the invasion
argilac the arrogant king of the
stormlands
argilac had his seat at storm's end a
castle considered the most impregnable
in westeros after hiron hall
arguelac may have been arrogant but he
wasn't stupid or a coward his lords
advised him to shut his gates and wait
out the siege
but he'd heard what had happened at
harrenhal and refused to die a suckling
pig cooked in his own castle
he would meet victory or defeat the same
way
with sword in hand
he called his banners and marched to
meet auras baratheon in the field thanks
to rayner's dragon meraxis aureus knew
argilac was coming how many men he had
and how fast he marched
so auras simply seized the high ground
and dug in on the hills to wait for
argelac
as the two armies approached the wind
rose to meet them and the rain poured
from the sky a gale which would give the
battle its name
the last storm
king argilac's lords urged him to wait
for the weather to die down
but a storm king saw that the rain was
blowing into the faces of the baratheon
men on their hills
and argilac outnumbered the baratheon
host two to one
with four times as many knights and
heavy horse
argilac attacked
three times agalak led his knights
against the baratheon line but the hills
were steep and the rain had beat the
earth to mud
the war horses founded and slipped and
the charges collapsed
the battle seemed lost
until argilac ordered his spearmen up
the hill
blinded by the rain the baratheons
didn't see them until it was too late
one hill fell then another
and another
until only one remained in the baratheon
center
if argilac could break through there
he could split the invading army and
flank both halves
argilac his men charged and the
baratheon line broke
revealing queen rhaenys and meraxis
argilac's vanguard burst into flame and
his men panicked
the victory charge fell into chaos and
aguila himself was thrown from his horse
but he didn't yield
when auris baratheon arrived he found
the old king holding off half a dozen
men another half dozen dead at his feet
or is dismounted to meet the king on
equal footing and offered argilac one
final chance to yield
argilac cursed him instead
as the storm raged around them the
grizzled old warrior and the bearded
upstart fought for life and kingdom
in the end
aguilar got his wish
he died
sword in hand
as word of agilex death spread his lords
and knights threw down their swords and
fled
ory sent his vanguard rode to storm's
end to claim argilac's castle for aegon
only to find the gates barred and the
walls manned
argilac's daughter had assumed his crown
and the new storm queen was as fond of
yielding as her father
she declared that auris would win only
bones blood and ashes here
but her men were weaker than her
and that night oris found argilac's
daughter delivered gagged chained and
naked to his camp
agalek had refused to give auris her
hand
now auras could have any part of her he
wished
but boris unchained the girl wrapped his
cloak around her and poured her a glass
of wine
he told her he would take the arms
banner and words of house durrandon to
honor her father's courage in the last
storm
conveniently orris had none of his own
to discard first
the crowned stag became the sigil of
house baratheon and storms end their
seat
argilac's daughter would even remain in
her home though as a lady instead of a
princess
the stormlands were now aegons
and as tribute aegon demanded the swords
of the men auris had defeated
for what purpose
arys didn't know
my brother robert baratheon had raised
the banners of storm's end our ancestral
castle
against the mad king aerys
john aaron of the vale and eddard stark
of the north stood with him and hoster
tully of the riverlands would join but
their lands were far from ours and
separated by the combined strength of
the west the reach
and king's landing itself
even robert's own lords were against him
it was the hardest choice i've ever made
my brother or my king
blood or honor
ares ruled by right of all the laws in
westeros
everyone knew the price of defiance
but they're a deeper older laws
the younger brother bows before the
elder
i followed robert
early in the war mace tyrell's
indecisive victory at ashford cut robert
off from storm's end
instead of pursuing robert and risking
his record mace tyrell turned east and
laid siege to our home
his vast army and navy encircled us and
prevented any resupply by land or sea if
a wagon tried to reach us it was burnt
if the ship tried to land it was sunk
we were locked in storm's end to starve
but robert commanded me to hold the
castle no matter the cost
he could ill afford to lose his ancient
seat which had never fallen
while robert smashed rhaegar on the
trident
my men ate the dogs
because their horses had already been
devoured
while the lannisters sacked king's
landing
we ate the rats
if the smuggler davos had not slipped
through the terrell blockade with his
onions
we'd have eaten our own dead
but i held the castle until lord eddard
remembered us
and marched to lift the siege
the tyrells didn't even put up a fight
and robert threw a feast to celebrate
lord eddard's victory
i was sent to the royal island
stronghold of dragonstone to deal with
viserys and daenerys the last surviving
targaryen children
before i arrived however they escaped
across the narrow sea robert was furious
he stripped me of storm's end
and gave it to that prancing fool renly
my younger brother
i could keep dragonstone
the baratheons say ours is the fury
i will show them
fury burns
[Music]
for our rebellion to succeed king's
landing had to be taken forcefully
no one was foolish enough to believe
that aerys was going to hand his crown
over peacefully
the mad king's reign needed to end
what tywin lannister's forces did was
unfortunate but it was necessary to
secure the iron throne and bring peace
and justice to the seven kingdoms
my glorious victory at the trident left
me wounded
but i sent my personal maester to attend
to sir barristan selmy instead his
wounds were more severe
even though sir barristan was a member
of aerys kingsguard and fought on the
opposing side
that man's bravery and loyalty was
something to behold
but this meant my wounds would take
longer to heal and i couldn't ride to
king's landing myself
i sent the one man i trusted over anyone
else in this world ned stark in my place
had i been able to ride perhaps i could
have reached king's landing sooner and
prevented some of the violence that
occurred when the lannisters entered the
city
still what lord tywin did was for the
greater good even what happened to
princess elia and her children
babies oh no theirs was the same cursed
blood that flowed within the mad king's
veins
they were dragon spawn and couldn't be
allowed to survive
what would they grow to be
loyal subjects
ned with his damn northern honor
he and i had our first major fight over
the deaths of the targaryen children
ned called it murder
murder
it was war
lord stark demanded that the lannisters
be held responsible for their crimes was
it a crime to put an end to a family of
lunatics born of incest
i wouldn't and still won't blame tywin
instead i sent ned stark south to finish
off the remaining targaryen loyalists